[Music]
we have Joey he's here in the studio
he's not miked up but he's back there
he's one of our more prolific fighting
heat wave lawyers he's waving at the
wall ah but he's behind our he's behind
our camera right now he's gonna be
playing in justice too while we talk
about it a game that generally across
the office I think even people who are
not traditional fighting game fans sorry
are not traditionally fighting game fans
are really enjoying it myself included
but Pete you gave it a 9 out of 10 you
betcha
were you surprised me yeah was I don't
like when I'm on the same wavelength as
you like stop thinking my thoughts no
get away from my brain gold mother box
what is that your gold mother has given
you a box right so Joey's gonna what you
gonna jump into the multiverse all right
Pete mutters what is this
it's multiverse is a place where events
are randomly generated and an event can
include a series of fights and then
there are rewards that are pitched to
you the characters you fight can come in
various different levels and wear
different gear as he Joey's of seconds
he got some bad modifiers so characters
have different levels and can wear gear
to upgrade their stats but modifiers are
the thing that make these fights super
interesting beyond difficulty because
they change things like environmental
effects physics rules controls even they
can be really annoying or they can be
super beneficial but instead of having
this variety that's regenerated on a
hourly daily or weekly basis is kind of
interesting and it's a great way to earn
rewards in the form of experience points
in gear gear being the thing that is
going to give this game longevity I
think for you know outside of the
competitive community who's going to
tear it apart and play strategically and
learn how to do that
the Metaverse and the gear will keep I
think more casual and average players
excited I think that this looks really
hot so fast because that's a modified
smart but yeah this is not how I
remember the game yesterday but uh what
is black Canary's power what did she do
she's yells yells there I was about to
say one of her finishers or what do a
supers write basically like throws a guy
down on the ground gets over him and
just does her teaching yell to him and
he's just
like freaking out isn't there an x-men
character that does that to Banshee
Banshee yeah I think so it's x-men right
sure yeah Marvin is upstairs it's really
bad a car hey I'm really so we want to
talk about the roster obviously that's
the main appeal for a lot of people
joeys are you scarecrow or Black Canary
joey is scarecrow that's a character
he's been playing a lot and I believe at
this point in the multiverse you have
the gear and everything right so yes in
the multiverse and in plenty of modes
you have the gear but most importantly
the gear stat boosts count here because
you're going up against enemies that
maybe have time much higher level than
you or they have really strong gear and
that helps kind of keep the variety
going and the you know the impetus to to
really look forward to gear and where
your best stuff it's really only you can
see the gear in any mode it's just the
stats are not active by Devere all
anytime in ranked man yes
so ranked matches are the competitive
stuff there's no option that's but you
can wear your gear unranked battles
players can decide for themselves if
they want stats hmm to carry over or not
what is gravity flux what's that
modifier uh that might make jumping a
little bit different I mean I haven't
seen all the modifiers I did Ross faster
like more grass drop faster you might
jump higher you might cover more ground
I'm not sure
good fight Joey yeah it's well done Joey
uh so Joey's scarecrow right here
ostensibly would look very different
from someone else's dirty sociopathic
legs of terror yes so yeah these
characters will look different cool
start answer your question uh yeah I'm
really I love the idea of spending like
a weekend with one character just
learning their moves but also getting
some cool-looking gear and some gear
that's gonna help me out further down
the road and that's really appealing to
me I like that
there are RPG mechanics in this cuz
we're those present in the first and
justice no okay
and so but there are some complications
that are worth talking about dude that
vomits on Costas yeah
does the bars blood into people's face
to make them comply that's so hot nice
way of just laying that out yeah so yet
this game uses a lot of different
currency systems to manage the
purchasing regeneration and modifying of
year and one of the complications
they're in that's not currency is the
level lock for gear so I'll you get a
lot of stuff in the story mode that
looks really cool but you can't wear it
until your little twenty and son all
gear but that's some stuff and that sort
of makes you feel like well crap I've
got this thing but I can't wear it uh so
the thing that you use where you can
either level up a character
automatically or change the appearance
of one type of gear to that of another
gosh the cat I'm explaining a very
complex system sorry we're not paying
any attention paying attention but a cat
interrupting lying out of nowhere is
this Christ keep going anyway this game
long story short this game is really
good at tempting you to spend real-world
money you don't have to do it to get a
lot out of it I didn't spend any and I
enjoyed the process of getting Superman
up to level 20 a few other characters up
to level 10 as I did that I earned more
gear I had access to more the gear I
already owned but it certainly is a
practice that is very obviously done to
tempt you into this necessary evil of
paid for it's not even DLC it's just
like paid for unlocks there's stuff that
you own in the game it seems very weird
but that's really only the bad thing I
can say about injustice to it it's
otherwise a really great fighting game I
mean I'm not on the evil level at all
anywhere close in any fighting game
series but I've played them since I can
remember and I typically love Japanese
games more often because I'd like the
flow of something like Street Fighter 5
versus the very deliberate staccato pace
of this game but once you the inputs are
so easy that once you actually start
playing for a while you see how to link
things together and what was worth what
was that first stiff and awkward becomes
pretty fluid after a while so that's
really good it's got an amazing story
mode the best cinematic work no the
realms ever done especially right that
oh yeah especially the face II animation
yeah it's top-notch I've I've never
liked yeah it's hard to a think of a
game other than like Metal Gear Solid 5
or Uncharted that really does mouth
movements and speech as well there was
there was a gift flowing round of Harley
Quinn I figure whether two heroes like
looking through a window and she was
chewing gum and talking and it just
looked like a filter on an actual lycra
shot of someone like
doing just that like it was saying it
seems like they actually did motion
capture for bodies in the mouth but like
all the movement in the face like in the
eyes and the brow that all that all
seems to be done just by hand in the
computer I don't know for certain but if
so that's a really interesting creative
approach because I think the mouth is
often the most awkward thing right which
also be super expressive in a comic book
universe that's gonna be your brow right
that's going to be things like that like
so it's a really interesting mix of the
two for all I know it could be all
facial capture but these look great yeah
as far as what dum why are you saying
I'm taking you now uh what can you say
as far as like myself not being like
anything remotely close to like a
fighting game player but like what would
you you mentioned like basically a
learning curve yeah like how long in do
you think well we get to the comfortable
factor and away from the button mashing
yeah it's a really good question I mean
so part of that is figuring out what
character you actually like yeah so the
story mode rolls out I'd say almost half
the cast and gives you a chance to play
them for a couple rounds and you can get
kind of a taste there but you know it's
once you start going into the multiverse
that you sort of start seeing different
ways of training the modifiers actually
teach you how to use characters in
different ways right and so if there's
one where you can't jump then you start
to think about like okay well what do I
do if I'm not jumping and attacking from
overhead you're using blocks and other
things sure yes I adore it organically
gives you experience in terms of like
how characters behave but going back to
the move lists
they're very they're very simple to
understand so once you start to memorize
those moves and you get comfortable
performing them you know one move at a
time you then start to just feel that
innate confidence that comes from just
pulling off something and going to the
next move right away I don't I think if
you spent like a handful of hours like
beat the story mode you know understand
the mechanics of the game like the
general way that every character works
and then you could just spend a couple
hours with another one in the mid overs
and you'd probably start to see a lot of
progress
I mean I take two Capcom's games kind of
like water these game nether realms
games have always been difficult for me
but this has been the easiest for me to
get into oh yeah sure it seems really
accessible but you said it was like even
if from whether you're a hardcore
fighting fan or someone like me who I'm
getting into it almost it's introducing
me to a ton of DC that I was not
familiar yeah I give a [ __ ] about decent
sex but here I am that was my next
question because I am neither a fighting
game person or a DC person like the only
thing I really care about is Batman yeah
um but I'm really intrigued especially
with the quality of the cinematic work
like I might actually kind of get into
these characters a little bit more I'm
kind of is it a good introduction to the
characters if you are it is a good
introduction to a twisted version of
most of these characters just I least
when the purpose of a story girlfriends
the premise of the story is that in the
last game that Superman was tricked into
killing Lois Lane setting off a nuclear
bomb in Metropolis
subsequently he is just pissed at the
world he's done being mr. nice guy he
wants to murder every criminal he wants
to kill them wipe them off the face of
the earth
Batman is like whoa dude I don't kill I
don't think we should kill super his
basic just I will screw you homey and
like so the rest of the game you know
there's a threat that appears some guys
trying to you know absorb the earth take
all its knowledge blah blah blah blah
but the sort of conflict between Batman
and Superman is really interesting so to
watch Superman be so hell bent on
murdering anyone who might be a criminal
and becoming this like totalitarian
leader that's super interesting
regardless if you care about DC Comics
and like the intricacies you know that
have been around for a while cuz we all
have an idea of Superman right right
clean-cut Clark Kent nice guy whatever
no he just wants to kill people whether
they've done a crime or not that's all I
mean and you know say what you will
about the last movies like it's tough to
represent Superman he's kind of like an
old archaic comic book hero so and he
still has that like I mean that friendly
confidence when he talks about killing
people it's like Jesus kind of cool cuz
Superman always like ends up boring me
right yeah exactly
I didn't think I would care yeah I
really enjoyed it
uh yeah it's
it intrigues me to is I don't want to
say it's immersive but it were it really
works right like you would just imagine
like a comic book and what if these
superheroes were matched with each other
and then and that was so well
represented with the cinematics and
those like super moves uh it's just it's
got his level of like epicness I guess
yeah that is really engaging part of
that's due to another realms hand here
because there are some like if you look
at the the plot points that bring some
of these characters together in the
story mode like outside of Batman and
Superman it's kind of just like yeah I
see you guys you know this is an excuse
for you to bring these characters
together the story reason doesn't make
much sense but it's all elevated by
nether realms ability to sort of like
you know stir up drama and like darkness
and kind of like you know conflict and
stuff so it NetherRealm deserves a lot
of credit for what they've done here
with DC's properties absolutely yeah and
the maps I think are really well done
and X in their execution of like there
was like the training mode was basically
all I've gotten into so far it has like
you know Batman and Superman out on the
street I just love the cinematic value
of this like a spotlight comes on from a
helicopter looking at you and it's like
yeah this kind of feels like again like
like a cinematic experience like
everyone is watched watching this epic
fight uh and here maybe not so much in a
bar which is funny but like I love those
scene changes to how you can do that
that seems it's just fun to watch yeah
you have any characters that you what
are your favorite characters that you
put been playing uh so I because I was
trying to hit level 20 I played Superman
a lot because through the story must
appear like level 9 or 10 so basic
anyway so I like Superman and it's it's
fun too because you unlock new abilities
for characters as you level up so you
can actually add to your repertoire and
then customize it when they have more
than a couple slots to like your actual
move us yeah oh cool
yeah dog uh so yeah I I kind of enjoyed
Superman I got one move added to his
move list that made him even more fun
for me but I've also been playing as
Robin
who in this case is Batman's son Damian
Wayne kind of [ __ ] sword - he's got
like a katana and he's really
interesting because he he his moves had
a lot of variations to them so one move
can you can control it to either go
standard distance short distance or long
distance and your enemy might not notice
it when you pull it off until you're
like in that animation already and
they're under attack
likewise he's you know every character
has a character trait with the press of
the circle button they can get like a
buff or they can call in like an assist
character his is he throws a Batarang
into the ground depending on what other
button he put he presses while hitting
circle he can either teleport to that
Batarang Mattern can attack someone else
or can explode is like a smoke screen oh
wow yeah so he is really fun because
he's one of those characters that is
deceptive right and that's kind of what
I like to do I'd like enlike el fuerte
from Street Fighter 4 if you ever played
that character and he's like a little
bit unpredictable they move very
differently but the nature of how they
fight come along those lines
Robin looks like someone I would like I
was telling you I'm not really good at
I'm not good at fighting game so I need
someone who the reach yeah so I don't
have to worry about my positioning as
much and mate looks like scarecrow might
be pretty good with that scarecrow is
good his his hook and chain pretty easy
to get like moves that'll give you space
Superman though has very easy
projectiles that you can throw across
the screen mm-hmm
of course there are characters such as
scarecrow who can teleport by going
underground and appearing somewhere else
and so you know there's ways to get
around that yeah there's there's 28
characters here Darkseid costs money at
launch which some people are upset about
other people are upset that I think
there's like six characters that are
announced for DLC so far and kind of
like a oh nine and and kind of like
Mortal Kombat X you know there's going
to be a version this game that has all
the characters but as we've seen with
campaigns like that of Skullgirls one
character in a fighting game can cost a
couple hundred thousand dollars to
produce yeah so with 28 here and a huge
variety among that cast to me I don't
think it's that bad that they have these
care
is coming down the road [ __ ] you know
it's there's so much to see already and
this game just has so many modes I think
whether you're like a hardcore you know
competitive player or a novice right
just like you know keep yourself going
yes the gear system currency stuff a
[ __ ] but outside of that I'd say this is
a you know a very robust fighting game
and perhaps one of the most robust um
sense a game like oh yeah there's a lot
of weird fighting games out there with
adventure modes I'll just leave it at
that
yeah I mean you saw it was awesome you
said in a lot of ways this feels like
what nether realm has been working
toward with their games even like with
Mortal Kombat X absolutely I mean the
the roots in Mortal Kombat are very
evident in this and in the first
injustice but you know like they've
gotten rid of things like QuickTime
events in cinematics right like I think
that's the thing that people complain
about they persisted with for a while to
not see them here is like they must have
listened because clearly they thought
that was a good idea when their audience
told them otherwise yeah I mean there's
just so much to it like even the
multiverse in Mortal Kombat that was the
living tower but there was also this
like weird like thing were you exploring
graveyards and Mortal Kombat X and like
a first-person mode and like getting
into it was just strange this is sort of
like you could see how they've taken
those pieces looked at them critically
and found out okay how do we put these
together so it's not this convoluted
weird way of giving people more to do
yeah how does it make sense in the
context of this world and in what people
actually want from the game do we know
who those nine characters are gonna be I
can think of a few cuz Nightwing's not
in this yet right which is weird
well like night I think Nightwing is you
fight him in the game I think he's a
alternate skin because once you equip
sets of gear for certain characters they
can have new abilities or transforming
in in the kind of subtle ways but yes
he's different than Robin but I'd be
kind of fights similar to Robin he's an
alternate skin for Robin I think so
Lorelei's doesn't that not make sense
wasn't yeah Damian wasn't night wasn't
night wake up tell you what is you know
he's got an alternate skin it's not an
alternate skin as much as you get the
weapon and he fights more like Nightwing
doesn't he use like so that's the two
short staff things isn't that basically
just an alternate skin god
yeah that's weird I'd rather have you
know he's at what a he's getting at what
I'm getting at is he's not a separate
character
Deathstroke's not in this either uh no
so you're gonna see like Red Hood
sub-zero from Mortal Kombat's coming
over um it's a couple more I just can't
remember Red Hood was what's his name
wasn't that Dick Grayson revived I don't
know about the Robin Hood died I don't
know
hmm no I want to play Green Arrow I like
Green Arrow the first game a lot like
that's getting has different elemental
arrows and stuff there's a I've never
heard of Captain cold before in my life
yeah I also yeah cheetah so Captain Cold
has the odd myth we have a video on
gamespot.com
explaining who cheetah is yeah um you
mentioned like QuickTime events which
Bruce I was from the last game right yes
it was in the last game and it was in
Mortal Kombat X as well it is it taken
form into that clash system that I keep
seeing pop-up you know when I save
QuickTime events I meant like during
cutscenes in the story mode those wagers
oh okay sorry
those wagers are you can initiate them
and then you bank your what you want to
call it your meter and thank you me your
meaning so wager you wager it right so
essentially you know you each have like
let's say four meters right yeah four
sections if you wager for the other
person wagers to you're going to win the
clash but depending on if you're the
attacker or the defender you're either
going to take off your opponent's health
or you're going to regain some health
yourself but the sort of risk they're in
is that you're cashing in meter and the
more media meter you have the more ways
you have to get out of combos the more
ways you have to do powered up super
moves right so it's sort of like a
give-and-take and there's a mind game
because you don't know what the other
person is doing it's it's a pretty
interesting system honestly it's sort of
I mean it's very unconventional how do
you engage that so once you lose the
first half of your meter which is like
the gray portion and you're down to red
right then it's just a matter of using
the l2 button and I forget the other one
but yeah that triggers it you can each
only do it once per fight and again only
when you're on your second health bar
cool what is it can you do green arrows
super move Joe
nevermind what is this truth oh no I've
seen it's the is that they have
something to the Apple was that just his
victory thing maybe that's his victory
yeah he shoots an apple in there maybe
there's an intro or something I don't
know um
yeah I'm really gonna I want to keep
playing this are you still like learning
any characters or you have you kind of
had to move on to a new game for a
review or anything there's actually just
been a lot of reviews to manage since I
put this review up but no I want to keep
playing as Robin I really like his
character and now there's more people
playing and the game will be out
tomorrow that right it's already out yes
yeah yeah um saltar there it's more
people to play yeah that's I say it does
look like Zoltan I said um yeah I wanna
I want to find like a three or four
characters I really like and try to get
good with them I'm really stoked for
Tekken 7 though that's what I'm looking
forward to what is that out June early
June first week of June yeah what it is
is that the only oh and then mob
what's it Marvel and Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite whatever you know that's called
and those that the Capcom fighting games
are kind of much faster pace right not
as stiff as nothing realms right but the
upcoming one is dumbed down yeah so but
this is accessible it seems like nether
realm made this accessible in a really
good way that doesn't sacrifice the
hardcore totally yeah I think it's tough
as [ __ ] to do yeah like I've played some
people online that I just I can't
believe the things they're doing and
it's like that's they must feel happy
with this game because they're doing
some impressive [ __ ] yeah it's also
something a scrub like me could pick up
yeah and just enjoy it even if you're
not on a competitive level yeah and
they're actually just the last thing
I'll mention there is a way to so-called
compete without actually fighting so the
characters that you build and raise you
can build a team that fight as AI so
three characters you upload them to the
server you can challenge other people's
characters and if you win those fights
which are automated you can get some
rewards every day and then people can
challenge you when you're not playing
and so you want you actually watch the
fights that you initiate play out and
you can like fast-forward them up to
like four times normal speed if you want
no way but school but you think about it
this way right like yeah you can't pull
off like an infinite combo or whatever
in a fight but you have built a squad of
Fighters that's really good
can still take someone down even if
you're not absolutely in control of it
that's awesome it's not something for
everyone but it's something for people
who are intimidated by traditional
online like and you're you're
legitimately watching this is over here
you're watching it another guy and you
can see so Godzilla was a bad man
similarly this is a is getting rekt yeah
I mean you can play this at normal speed
but it's also fun to do it at
fast-forward because you that's other
person I'm so sorry interrupt around
another person's team that they've
uploaded to a strategy this is all AI oh
okay oh I thought I was an actual person
okay and then yeah you can get like up
to five item boxes a day whether you're
attacking or defending but you also do
earn experience for these fights so like
when I was doing my review and needed to
level up Superman when I learned that I
was like well shoot I can go make dinner
and level up Superman by like every 30
seconds looking at my ps4 and like
hitting X a couple times yeah you don't
get a lot of experience it's not like
you can really like fudge it but it's
enough to make incremental differences
especially when you're at a lower level
it's like a kind of a what do you want
to say like a JRPG that you can automate
stuff like that battles about to say it
sounds like the gambits and final
fantasy 12 you don't have much control
over how they fight okay that's the
that's the primary difference there so
it's just like you've built up this
character you've leveled up this
character and you kind of send them off
to do work for you while you're not
playing yes the one thing that's a
little inconvenient with this is that
they will retain the levels that you've
given them I believe automatically but
if you equip items to characters outside
of the AI battles and you go into the AI
battle you have to reconstruct your
team's loadout because it's all saved on
a server it doesn't transfer
automatically and maybe you want to have
characters that are equipped differently
than the ones you're using outside of it
so you have to keep that in mind like
there were a few fights that got in AI
battles where I was like oh crap this
build is hours old like I didn't intend
for that to happen but you're not really
losing much if you lose you lose thirty
seconds of your time and whatever has a
fighting game had something like this
before not that I can think of but I
very well could be what about people who
care about rush for head to his rank oh
I always like to think of smash in a
separate category than I think of a game
like this I never kind of associate them
yeah I was questioning in my head when I
was
my review like you know yes as a game it
has something for everyone
isn't that smash but I think for smash
it's so much about competition this
offers a lot of different pursuits where
it's not just whether you win or lose it
makes you feel happy about playing the
game
smash also lacks a lot of a RPG
progression at this game well of course
of course um that's the stuff yeah uh
yeah I really wanna play more of this I
definitely want to try out like flash
green arrow uh I don't know I kinda want
to see what Captain colds deal is cuz I
you know like to replace mr. freeze what
you gotta have a good excuse there is a
scheme good for mr. freeze okay gotcha
lose him
cool uh your review is up nine out of
ten on GameSpot you want to read that
yeah buddy you don't want to read it
probably you wrote it I did I wrote it
with my girlfriend playing black desert
online behind me with her two friends
without a headset so I had three voices
talking in my ear the whole time nice
but somehow I wrote a review okay yeah
you played all weekend I put yeah I've
been playing since Wednesday at Thursday
and yeah this weekend if I wasn't
writing I was playing cool so you can go
check that out if you're watching right
now you can go read that on GameSpot
[Music]